yes she has biological parents but every
child that has been adopted has
biological parents that doesn't mean
that we aren't her parents Todd and
Julie Chrisley react to reports that
their adopted daughter Chloe's
biological mom wants to regain custody
of her after a judge sentenced the
reality TV couple to more than a decade
in prison for various Financial crimes I
don't care what you say about that but
if you come at my kids or you come about
my wife oh God then I'm gonna drag you
Chloe is actually Todd and Julie's
granddaughter the child of Todd's son
Kyle Todd and Julie adopted Khloe at a
very young age and have raised her as
their own I have officially raised
children my entire life and just I was
that close to a clean getaway and then
all of a sudden here comes my club bug
knocking on the door we're starting over
if I need to be the one to step up and
put a foot in Kyle's ass and keep him
moving in order for Chloe to have a good
role model then Kyle and I are going to
keep doing that dance she has that
Chrisley we call it Chrisley too
um she has that Chrisley attitude and
you know she will put Chase in his place
and Grayson but earlier this week
Chloe's biological mom Angela Johnson
spoke with TMZ about her plans to go
back to court and get Chloe back home
claiming she was cut out of her life in
response to Chrisley's reptiles ET quote
Todd and Julie are saddened by the
unfortunate and misleading narrative
currently being portrayed in the media
regarding Chloe hello hello
how are you the devil ah Chloe the two
obtained custody of Chloe in 2016 amid
Kyle's struggles with addiction Angela
Todd and Julie originally shared
parental Duty but the Chrisleys were
awarded Soul custody after Angela was
arrested for allegedly filing a false
application for Medicaid well she was
she is precious as can be she's the boss
she truly is she is the boss Todd and
Julie's daughter Lindsay spoke out about
the custody claims on her podcast she's
defending her parents and says Chloe
should stay within their family when
Todd and Julie go to prison the story
was that she wanted Chloe to be returned
in her terms home
and Chloe is home and I want to make
that very clear
um Chloe has been with my parents uh
roughly since she was six months old
medical records school records court
documents will prove this that's not
Angela's word my word or their word but
that is the truth her first birthday
party was broadcast on national TV it
really was a perfect party for a
one-year-old
it's very disheartening when you see
things that are being said that are just
so blatantly false to remove her from
the situation and where she is now
looking at all of the things
collectively would be so many
transitions for her that she would not
be able to cope
foreign